today for our daily cancellation i'm
canceling phds
and i'll explain why uh this starts uh
recently a a phd
expert scolded me on twitter for my
objectional opinions on gender
and other related topics you know i made
the argument as i made on the show that
one of the primary tools used to
sexualize children in our culture
is trans indoctrination and because of
that
dr logan levkov swooped in to expose and
annihilate my transphobia
with these scorching rays of her
superior education and intellect
she countered that quote the primary
tool in our culture used to create
fear and hate about gender identity is
matt walsh which is a flattering claim
by the way that sadly i can't possibly
live up to though i wish i could
and she reminded the reader that i am
not an expert in gender or sexuality and
therefore
nobody should listen to me she is an
expert though or at least that's the
title she's given to herself
uh her bio on her website informs us
that she is a sex educator
a quote internationally recognized
expert on sexuality and relationships
and a quote thought leader in the field
of human sexuality and personal
relationships
on top of all that she's incredibly
humble now as an uneducated bumpkin
myself with only a high school diploma
to my name
i sensed an opportunity here to be
educated so i sat down at my computer in
my tattered
dungarees with a piece of straw hanging
out of my mouth this is how she'd
probably imagine the scene anyway
and i asked the good the good doctor the
question that i've been posing
to proponents of left-wing gender theory
for years now
what is a woman that's my classic
question you've heard it from me many
times
i've not been able to extract a coherent
response from anyone on the left
no matter how often i try but i figured
that if anyone could rise to the
challenge
it would be a phd who is recognized
internationally
as an expert in the field of knowing
what gender is
so her first answer to the question was
kind of disappointing though she said
quote
gender is a social construct womanhood
or manhood is not defined by
reproductive organs or genitals
assigned sex at birth is also not a
binary and sexual orientation is not the
same as gender identity it's fairly
simple
and you're welcome now there are a lot
of problems here beginning with the fact
that she didn't define the word she
didn't answer the question
instead she offered up a whole bunch of
additional vague concepts that need
their own definitions
what does she mean by assigned sex who
is the sex
assigner god nature surely she must know
that doctors at the hospital don't
assign
sex it's not as though they're pulling
babies out of the womb and randomly
attaching boy or girl genitals to them
like potato head dolls
doctors notice or observe the sex they
don't assign it
she also gives the classic gender is a
social construct canard now i call that
a classic but we should note that it's a
very new classic
prior to the arbitrary invention of
gender as a human
a human identity which is a concept
largely pioneered by the way by
a a pedophilic quack name named john
money who tried
tried out these theories on two young
boys who later went on to kill
themselves that's a story that deserves
more of a focus
than i can give it right now prior to
any of that
gender was a grammatical category words
had gender people had sex
uh we are now told that people have both
sex and gender
but the people telling us that have
never quite been able to explain how the
two are different and why we need
both concepts plus as i've argued many
times the false sex verse gender
dichotomy contradicts the trans
narrative as invariably
it's a child's affinity to the gender
constructs of the other sex
that is cited as a reason to transition
them to that sex in the first place but
if the constructs are artificial
then why assume that a child's
identifying with them has any deeper
meaning at all in other words
why can't he just be a feminine boy
you know feminine by society standards
boy are we not reinforcing the
constructs by insisting that feminine
boys are actually girls because only
girls can be feminine
this answer from our expert simply
doesn't work on any level unfortunately
um so i you know i asked again and she
tried again a few minutes later
after consulting with her expert level
phd books
she said what is a woman anything she
wants to be
this is about the caliber of insight
that i might expect from a fortune
cookie
and they give you fortune cookies for
free with the order of kung pao chicken
i really hate to think how much dr logan
spent on university courses in order to
attain
a similar level of enlightenment so
that's kind of disturbing
needless to say anything she wants to be
cannot be a valid definition for the
word woman definitions are supposed to
tell you
what a thing is this definition tells me
almost nothing about women except that
apparently they're shape-shifters
which is an interesting fact no doubt
but i don't feel that i'm much closer to
understanding the concept of womanhood
fundamentally so uh you know i had to i
had to press further and
finally our sex and gender expert made
one more attempt
and offered this up as a definition she
says i was giving you more info than you
asked for because you clearly didn't
know the difference between assigned sex
and birth and gender
obviously that was too complex for you a
woman is someone who identifies as
female female identity and female
assignment
may be different okay now we're getting
somewhere
or are we let's break this down a little
bit
a woman is someone who identifies as
female
let's try to understand this what is a
female well
female is someone with two x chromosomes
and a vagina and a uterus
okay what does identify as mean well
that can mean
any number of things identify could mean
recognize or observe
you know we say that a witness may
identify the suspect meaning
hey that guy that's the guy i recognize
him
is this what identify as female means
women are people who recognize that they
have two x chromosomes
and that can't be it because obviously
males can't recognize 2x chromosomes
within themselves because they don't
have them
and what about women who have them but
don't recognize them are they not women
so that doesn't work now dictionary.com
has another definition that might be
might help us a little bit more it says
it says
identify can also be a verb meaning to
associate oneself in feeling
interest action etc with a specified
group or belief system
okay now this seems to this seems to be
what we're talking about right
but a number of problems present
themselves first of all how can you
associate yourself
in feeling an interest with a certain
set of chromosomes
and even if you can is there not
obviously a
difference between the group that has
the chromosomes
and the group that identifies with the
group that has it
if identifies as denotes anything that
it must by definition to note that there
is a difference between those
who have or those who are
and those who identify as
and if there is no difference then why
do we even need this identify as
business at all
why do we need the prefix trans so it
seems we're left with
women who are females by definition
and then this other group who are men
some of whom have some kind of hazy
ill-defined
vague affinity for some aspects of what
our culture considers feminine
now you can call that ladder group
whatever you want or whatever they
want except you cannot call them women
because women are precisely the group
they identify with
which means they are not in it but
outside it and identifying with it
so this definition doesn't work either
women cannot by definition be
both females and not females given that
male and female the only two options
if women are females or males then women
aren't anything in particular
and we're back to not having a
definition the good doctor after
hundreds of thousands of dollars spent
on our education and so many years as an
expert traveling the globe to deliver
her expertise and
and and educate everybody and and pass
on her wisdom
apparently still doesn't have an
understanding on the topic of gender
that rises even to the level of my
seven-year-old son and this is why we're
canceling phds
you're still allowed to get one if you
want i will permit it in my in my
generosity
but just know that getting a whole bunch
of certificates and calling yourself an
expert
doesn't make you one in fact in this
country today you can be a certified
expert in a field
without knowing the first damn thing
about it
what we find is that for some people the
process of education is a process of
finding long and windy and tortured ways
around
facts and truth many of our experts are
experts at sounding smart
while being stupid in other words and
that's because
the process of learning won't amount to
actual knowledge if you're not learning
with the intent of pursuing truth
much of the learning that goes on in our
country especially in the higher
institutions
is learning ways around truth not ways
to it and that's how you end up with
legions of experts who are essentially
large grapefruits with wigs and faces
drawn on in sharpie
at least they are comparable to
grapefruits when it comes to their depth
of real knowledge and understanding
and so phds are canceled the good doctor
is cancelled
and just for good measure i'm also going
to cancel everyone who calls themselves
a doctor when they're not medical
doctors because
come on you know we all know that's
pretty lame so stop that too
uh everyone there is canceled thank you
for tuning in to the daily wire one of
the fastest growing conservative media
outlets in the entire country if you
enjoyed this video
be sure to give it a like and a
subscribe to our youtube channel so you
don't miss out on any of our content